en este video quiero hablarles sobre la
primera ley del movimiento de Newton la
primera ley dice todo cuerpo persevera
en su estado de reposo o
movimiento uniforme y rectilíneo a no
ser que sea obligado a cambiar su estado
por fuerzas impresas sobre él esta es la
definición que está en
Wikipedia Bueno vamos a comprender un
poco esto tenemos que todo cuerpo o
cualquier objeto va a permanecer tiende
a permanecer en su estado de
reposo o su estado de movimiento
uniforme y
rectilíneo a no ser que sea obligado a
cambiar su estado por fuerzas impresas
sobre él o alguna fuerza que actúe sobre
este cuerpo y debe ser una fuerza no
balanceada les voy a explicar esto un
poquito más
adelante Bueno vamos a ver la primera
parte de esta ley tenemos algo que está
en reposo por ejemplo nos imaginamos que
tenemos pues una piedra una piedra azul
y no sé nos la imaginamos que está este
pues en una cama de
pasto Bueno si estamos observando esta
piedra vemos que no se va a mover no le
va a pasar nada va a seguir en reposo
siempre y cuando ninguna cosa suceda o
ninguna fuerza actúe sobre ella entonces
este Bueno pues esto realmente no no hay
nada extraño sobre esto es bastante
obvio lo que no es tan obvio es esta
segunda parte de movimiento uniforme y
rectilíneo Pero bueno Permítame Hacer
una
aclaración en donde
eh esta persona bueno Esta es la primera
ley de Newton Esta persona es
Newton Newton
Uy okay
Newton y se preguntarán Bueno si esta es
la primera de de Newton él es Newton Qué
hace esta persona aquí Bueno Esta
persona es otro titán de la ciencia
llamado
Galileo
Galilei es
Galileo y mucho de lo que eh es viene en
esta ley de Newton realmente lo que hizo
Newton fue modificar eh la ley de la
inercia de Galileo y incluirla eh
modificada entre su conjunto de leyes
del movimiento así que bueno hay que
reconocer el trabajo de Galileo que es
una parte una gran parte una parte muy
importante eh de cómo Newton eh pudo
eh crear o bueno más bien establecer
eh este enunciado esta ley bueno
regresando a esta parte bueno ehas
pasamos la primera parte es cuando
tenemos algo en estado de reposo por
ejemplo habíamos puesto nuestra nuestra
piedra A menos que va a permanecer en
ese estado A menos que otra Paz otra
cosa suceda algo eh al una fuerza fuera
de balance entre có a qué me refiero a
que no esté balanceada bueno yo puedo
tener una fuerza actuando aquí en mi
piedra en este sentido y también puedo
tener otra fuerza en sentido opuesto de
la misma magnitud Y si tengo ambas se
van a equilibrar y la piedra no se va a
mover a lo mejor Este ejemplo de la
piedra en el suelo pues como que no
queda muy claro vamos a imaginarnos otro
escenario donde tenemos aquí este una
pista de hielo y
encima tenemos un
bloque de hielo aquí y lo mismo tenemos
este Bueno podemos imaginarnos que estoy
aplicando una
fuerza de este lado y también otra
fuerza en lado en el lado contrario en
el sentido contrario que son de la misma
magnitud por lo que mi bloque pues
finalmente no se va a mover y aquí tengo
unas fuerzas en balance o balanceadas
estas fuerzas son
balanceadas y bueno la forma lo que se
refiere a esto de que puede cambiar su
estado por fuerzas no balanceadas
impresas sobre el objeto y regresando lo
que los decía esta segunda parte en lo
que se refiere al movimiento o un objeto
que esté en un movimiento uniforme y
rectilíneo pues esto no es tan obvio Ya
que en nuestra experiencia humana todo
termina deteniéndose en algún momento
dado eh No vemos algo que permanezca en
movimiento por
siempre en nuestra experiencia Eh pues
bueno si queremos que algo se siga
moviendo tenemos que ponerle energía
sin embargo pues esto o esta conclusión
de que se si hay algo que está
moviéndose y no hay nada que interfiera
con ese movimiento este objeto se va a
seguir moviendo en velocidad constante
este de movimiento uniforme y rectilíneo
podemos decir que es una velocidad se va
a estar moviendo a una
velocidad
constante
así que bueno si yo tengo algo en reposo
aunque tengo fuerzas en balance si yo le
aplico a esto otra fuerza mayor que no
está
balanceada entonces mi objeto pues se va
a mover se va a mover En la dirección de
esta fuerza y
eh nuestra experiencia Cuando tenemos
algo que se está moviendo no sé por
ejemplo una pelota de tenis tengo mi
pelota de tenis y esta la estoy lanzando
en el aire se va a detener en algún
momento va a caer Qué pasa lo que sucede
es que en nuestra planeta pues tenemos
lo que es la fuerza de gravedad que va a
hacer que esta pelota de tenis en algún
momento pues caiga hacia el suelo o en
el caso del hielo este si tuviéramos una
pista infinita y
en esta parte Aunque nosotros pensamos o
sentimos que el hielo es este liso si
nos vemos a nivel molecular vamos a ver
que su superficie realmente pues tiene
rugosidades es este no es este
completamente Lisa Entonces el hielo
tiene esta forma de superficie estos
huecos o estas esta forma que al momento
de estarse moviendo una contra otra pues
se van a detener va a haber
y la fricción pues va a hacer que este
movimiento se
detenga si estuviéramos en el espacio
donde no tenemos aire Ah porque también
tenemos la resistencia al aire este
tanto este bloque de hielo al moverse
hacia acá va a estar este golpeando
estas partículas de aire que también lo
van a estar frenando lo mismo con
nuestra pelota de tenis llega acá pero
va a estar
eh todo en toda su trayectoria va a
estar colisionando con pequeñas
moléculas de aire que le van a estar
restando fuerza y velocidad y van a
lograr que pues se detenga en algún
momento
Eh bueno otra forma de que podemos eh
tratar de entender esto que es bueno es
algo impresionante el que estas personas
se hayan dado cuenta o se hayan
imaginado una realidad en donde algún
objeto si es lanzado o está en
movimiento si no hay aire y si no hay
gravedad por ejemplo en el espacio
profundo pues ese objeto se va a
continuar moviendo
indefinidamente sobre todo yo creo que
fue obra de Galileo que él el que era
quien estaba observando las órbitas de
los planetas y él Pudo haberse imaginado
que al estar los planetas en el espacio
pues e los planetas nunca se ve que
disminuyan su velocidad o que se
detengan siempre están girando entonces
es posible que eso le haya dado pie que
se imaginara que hay circunstancias en
la vida real o en el mundo real donde
estas cosas ocurren que está algo en
movimiento y se va a mantener en
movimiento A menos que otra fuerza fuera
de balance
interfiera otra forma de de entender
esto eh de más en la vida cotidiana
ustedes se pueden imaginar que están
viajando dentro de una avión
eh supongamos que este es el
avión Aquí van
ustedes y este avión Pues bueno se está
moviendo está volando en el
aire pero si ustedes se imaginan que
están en este avión y este avión no
tiene ventanas y el avión se está
moviendo a una velocidad constante no
hay turbulencia ni ninguna otra cosa que
altere el movimiento si esto está
cerrado y ustedes están adentro de la av
No hay forma en que ustedes se den
cuenta si el avión se está moviendo o
está detenido Entonces es otra manera de
conceptualizar y darse cuenta que el
estado de reposo o el estado de
movimiento uniforme continuo o
rectilíneo en velocidad constante no son
tan diferentes realmente entre sí si
están en estado
puro Vamos a continuar en el siguiente
video